with one of nevada's most well-known
criminal defense attorneys about the
verdict
the charges and much more she joins us
live in studio
thank you for joining us vanessa well it
is rare for a jury to convict a police
officer in
america criminal defense attorney david
chesnov points to a strategy
used by the prosecution here to tell the
jury this wasn't
prosecution against police it was
prosecution against a man who
happened to be a police officer again
usually jurors are
sympathetic to law enforcement but this
jury came back with a verdict of guilty
on all three counts
chesnov says he believes both the
prosecution
and defense did a good job in this case
and he tells me he believes there's not
much derek chauvin's
defense attorney could do especially
because of the video of chauvin kneeling
on george floyd's neck
i mean i i've thought of different
defenses maybe
some maybe some kind of a mental illness
defense because
to have somebody standing there in the
face of people
telling him that the person is dying and
not to do anything it's just
there was something either very sadistic
about this guy
i mean it was like a lynching
jurors deliberated for about 10 hours
before delivering the verdict
we're going to go to break now